we heard earlier in the program from
george eustis who said that
it's right for all these questions to be
looked at he did say on the face of it
that david cameron didn't do anything
wrong
and that the system in many ways is
actually
a pretty good one do you agree with him
well
i think what we're seeing in all of this
is that the era of tory sleeves is well
and truly
as well and truly back and what's
happened with you know
the green seals scandal is really quite
shocking you've got a former prime
minister
employed by a wealthy organization who
is then using
his personal relationships with existing
ministers including the chancellor of
the exchequer
and persuading them to do favors favors
that would not have been open
to other businesses or they didn't
organization they didn't do the favors
did they
didn't manage to persuade them to do the
favors they were rejected well we don't
entirely know do we because green still
did get out
greenfield did get access to the
framework loan schemes
and it's not inclined entirely clear how
they got access to that they were one of
only two unregulated banks
that were treated in that way we don't
know whether that was as a result of the
lobbying that david cameron was doing
now
what we've seen so far is a couple of
texts
exchanged between rishi sunak and david
cameron
in one of those the chancellor says that
he will push officials hard
to do favors for green sill that of
itself
may be a breach of the ministerial code
and that of itself
needs to be investigated because
ministers should be acting in a way that
is impartial and they should be pushing
things directly
onto their officials when this happens
but we haven't seen
all the texts or or the secret phone
calls that went on
between david cameron and rishi sunak
and we really need to in order to
understand exactly what's going on
going on we can't just dismiss this in
the way that mr eustis tried to do
earlier this morning on your show
so what i'm interested in because i
think it's very easy for you know labour
to throw away
a throw around words like cronyism
victoriously as you did
what exactly do you want to happen well
what
needs to change what we've been calling
for is an
open parliamentary investigation into
exactly what's been going on
lots of investigations but we've
this hasn't just started with green
still so a year ago in the house of
commons
uh when we had robert generic the
community secretary
involved in the west ferry scandal he
was he admitted he had broken the law
to do favors for a billionaire tory
party donor and helped him dodge 40
billion pounds
intact but the way to get around this
because and i
appreciate that there's lots of concerns
over lobbying about access
what needs to change well one of the
things that needs to change i'll use
that example if i can
if i can sophie because i wrote to the
cabinet secretary asking for an inquiry
into mr generic to see whether he had
broken the ministerial code the prime
minister blocked it
so the inquiry didn't happen and what
what seems to be going on here is that
we've got
you know the green seal case uh examples
with matt hancock the examples with west
very
and robert generic in every case number
10 blocks the investigations
so we know that there aren't there well
they're trying to mark their own
homework that you know the man that
they've put in charge of the green cell
investigation nigel boardman
is on the board of a bank with very
close links to the conservative there's
a lot of
other inquiries going on already it
feels to me like the problem isn't that
we haven't got enough inquiries we've
got loads of inquiries the problems is
no one seems to know what should
actually
change what we need is an open inquiry
not one where the conservatives are
marking their own homework
because boris johnson has shown
repeatedly over the past year he's not
interested in exposing what's going
wrong and he's not interested in
stopping
what's going wrong if we have an
independent parliamentary
inquiry into what's going on open and
transparent and david
cameron's own words sunlight is the best
disinfectant
well let's expose this whole situation
to that sunlight
let's see exactly what's going on let's
pull in everybody to
public hearings that the public can see
as well as mps let's find out what's
going on
and then let's put in place the measures
that will prevent it
from recurring one of them might well be
that the prime minister should not be
the person who decides
whether there are investigations into
his own ministers
for breaches of the ministerial code
perhaps an independent person should be
doing that
so the prime minister can't then be
accused of covering up wrongdoing by his
own ministers
is there an argument that labour would
be
just the same as this if you were in
power and if you look at the evidence
right if you look at this
for example david evans story in the
newspaper today
labour's general secretary won a series
of taxpayer contracts from croydon
council
labour on one council deputy leader
happens to be the mother of his child
is this evidence that if labor gets a
chance they would do exactly the same
thing it's just that the fact that
you're so far away from power
for so long i saw that the conservatives
have
put this out and if that's the best they
can do to try and deflect from what
they're doing then it's a pretty
miserable attack okay how about this
what david was doing it was it was an
open and transparent procurement con
process which is the polar opposite of
what's been going on with green seal
or the con or the company that matt
hancock has shares in that he failed to
declare
that's been winning millions of pounds
in contracts
that's exactly the point you did you
didn't declare that his family had had
shares in this in this company
that's been winning millions of pounds
in congress
in exactly the way that he was obliged
to i don't think i did i don't think he
did and that's why we need an
investigation into that as well
it's repeatedly happening with the
minister of ministry talk about green
saw them
the shadow defense secretary john healey
also lobbied the government to allow
greenster access to covert lanes
he says it was the right thing to do
because he was trying to protect a still
plant in his constituency
well presumably david cameron thought it
was the right thing to do as well it's
just that he happened to have better
constituency mps
are asked to act on behalf of businesses
and their constituencies as constituency
mps
that's part of the job david cameron is
not an mp
david cameron was being employed by
green seal directly and being paid
to try and get them preferential
treatment from the chancellor of the
exchequer
who was a friend of his whose number he
had on whatsapp
an mp acting for a local business is a
million miles away from what's been
going on
with this situation and i'm really i'm
afraid you know the kind of behavior
we've been seeing from this government
is not the behavior you would expect
of an advanced western democracy it's
what you would associate with a timpot
dictatorship and britain deserves an
awful lot better than that we
we have to shine a light on the sleaze
that is corroding the heart of this
government
so we can stop it uh and get back to the
kind of government that the british
people can have trust in
okay i'm keen to ask you a couple more
things about covered while i have you as
well now nhs providers are very worried
about the backlog
in the nhs caused by the pandemic they
said it could be five years to clear
how concerning is that well it's
incredibly concerning i've had
constituents coming to me now that have
had
very urgent operations for things like
um cancer
delayed by months now frankly if you've
got cancer you can't afford to wait
for months i mean part of the problem
here is that the nhs had already been
underfunded by the time we went into
this
pandemic the pandemic was always going
to make it more more difficult
but we really need now to be looking at
everything that can be done to make sure
that people that have urgent treatment
needed in the nhs can
can go ahead and get it and one way to
do that is to make sure
that we keep a lid on on the situation
with covid right now so we have to keep
rolling out the vaccination
program but also we need to do much
better with
test contact tracing and testing once we
get out of this initial period because
new variants of the
disease are coming out and we need to
identify them and crack down on them
quickly
third thing we need to do is keep
control of the borders so the government
still does not have a comprehensive
quarantine program should david people
coming into the country should david
cameron still be going to
uh tammy cameron slip should boris
johnson still be going to india given
that
i think he shouldn't be no i mean there
are there are new variants emerging all
around
all around the world the government is
telling people don't travel if you don't
have to absolutely
travel i can't see why the prime
minister can't conduct his business
with the indian government by zoom so
many of us do that
these days and i think the prime
minister all of us in public life need
to try and set an example
of much rather the prime minister did it
by zoom than traveling to india
uh just finally yuga poll this week gave
the conservatives a 14 point lead over
labour now i know it's just one poll
but you've got elections in just a few
weeks time and it feels like the polls
are going in the wrong
direction at what point do you start to
panic it's just one poll let's wait and
see what happens in the elections
they're only they're only a few weeks
away after i've finished in your studio
i'm offering door knocking in
nottinghamshire with my colleagues so
i'm going to
hear what the voters have got to say and
we'll see on the 6th of may what they
what they think